gift of nil
gift of old bless the righteousness
guide my hand against the darkness my
final stand
fire breath I want to get to know you a
little bit more you have many friends
what about your sister I play your
dragons or whatever if you ask me to
code be hilarious what are you doing
what's it for
there's some serious stuff going down I
fine Giants I hunt Giants
I feel joyous cool yeah that's it
dark omens are totally cool a giant
comes in place and takes everything from
you and when it's done it's like
anything that made your life good was it
never even there Giants not real sweaty
[Music]
I know that no one likes me I know that
everything I do looks crazy
this isn't real we're gonna save this
town
[Music]
there are times where you have to ask
yourself so I want to live my life is a
coward
or a warrior
[Music]
[Music]
13 14 15 16 hi
are you playing the game I don't think
so
if you were I would join you all and now
I was here
we just moved here from Leeds England no
one here knows needs only London
stinky what's it for pray a little find
out what it is tribute to my spirit
guide oh that's interesting
hi nice meeting you
you have a pretty name and I like the
way you talk thank you what's your okay
thanks
you